it's interesting that five that I count
so far very conservative newspapers who
have not supported endorsed a Democrat
for a long time the Arizona Republic
since 1896 Cincinnati Enquirer 1916
Dallas Morning News 1940 the Houston
Chronicle the San Diego union-tribune
never support the Dumber they are doing
it magaz USA Today yeah has never
endorsed they still don't but they said
don't vote for this one right uh and
then magazines Rolling Stone The
Advocate wired have come out for Hillary
Rolling Stone who would have ever
thought that okay but here but just show
that just to show that the equal time
there are some lesser-known magazines
that have come out for Donald Trump
would you like to see is this unreal
Esther
less or no for example for Donald Trump
car and liar
they say mr. Trump owns lots of parts
and he lies his ass off what's not to
like
unpopular size is for Donald Trump they
raved you can make up practically
anything about climate change and this
will retweet it absolutely
truck is the obvious choice uh wine
aficionado
[Applause]
they say you don't see there's many
at the dog show American
sociopath
their endorsement reads while we can't
send to a process normal human emotion
something about this Trump family just
feels right good housekeeper magazine
[Applause]
we heartily endorse send your trouble is
if we don't he'll have us deported
modern mail-order bride magazine
they say hey we've done business with
this man and the check clears
this magazine translates as highlights
for child laborers and they say we
support the orange American who's whose
name we sew on the neckties
[Applause]
finally Barrett fancy magazine says
what's in his hand doesn't make him one
of us but what's on his head most
certainly does all right